[تصفيق]
السيدات الساده العلميون
الاعزاء صناديق الانتخابات داخل تركيا
اكثر من 99 في المئه
فتحها
اما
صناديق
خارج
الى النسبه وصلت الى 88
في المئه سيد رجب طيب باردو ان حصل الى
حلا وخمسين
في من الخارج
وسيد كريستار اولو 40 اما المعدل للخارج
داخل
الى الان نسبه
99,43 في المياه سيد رجب الطيب باردو ان
حصل على اثنين وخمسين.14 في المئه اما
السيد كريستاله حصل على
47.80 في الالعاب
من اعتبارا من
مليونين
كلى
مرشحين ونسبه
0.1 في مئه فقط هذه النسبه لن تغير النسبه
الموجوده
وبالتالي ونتيجه لهذه الانتخابات السيد
رجب طيب اردوغان اختير رئيسا للجمهوريه
التركيه خلال هذه الفتره
ومرحله في الانتخابات
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات نحن كنا حياديين
اشكروا جميعا المشاركين وجميع ممثلي
الاحزاب السياسيه في جميع
مراكز في جميع المحافظات والولايات والمدن
جميع المشاركين في
مراكز
اشكر جميع من قدموا الدعم النا في من اجل
نجاح هذه الانتخابات منذ الاعلان الاول
لتاريخي هذه
الانتخابات وحتى هذه اللحظه انتم
اعلميات اشكركم فردا فردا
وابارك نتائج هذه الانتخابات الشعب التركي
والجمهوريه التركيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات